Hey guys, listen, I'm super high energy. I'm high energy. I think I'm high energy. I'm probably the highest I've ever been. I just got a call from the high energy. I shot the coffee into the back of my knee. I'm on fire right now. I just pulled my car here.
I didn't even have time to let it drive. I need to turn it on. I just had two pints of hog and does. Hang on, guys. Let's make sure we get this episode started. We still got the gas. Ready? Here comes. We're going to set it I'm going to start. Wait, are you retiring from smartness? No, no, no, no, that's, that's, that's, that's, I'm not, wait, why are you?
Well, we do have a very great replacement waiting whenever you're ready to. It can, doesn't have to be now, it can be next year or whenever. I feel like it's sideswiped. I got it. I just want to give them a heads up. I want to, oh, you are not retiring. You're not retiring. Okay, no.
What I was going to say was Jesus. Sorry. How excited we are for Shiny winning the Tony. Oh, well, there's that. I mean, Sean Hayes. Yes, Sean Hayes won a fucking Tony. Oh, well, there's that. I mean, Sean Hays. Yes. You want to fucking Tony. Tony. Best actor for Good Night Oscar. I I know it's so funny. Very nice. Remember when remember when you said you were going to go do this play in Chicago, an idea that you had. you got this great writer and gosh, you're
scared and you don't know how it's going to go. Doug what's his name? Well, and you got great reviews and there was a possibility of it going to Broadway. You weren't sure. Do you remember you were in Scotty, where in that shitty apartment in Chicago right above the, the, the, the, the fire station? Yeah. Yeah.
Please take my word. Got such a deal on it. And then you go to Broadway and you're not quick name of the theater Jason name of the theater best go the spicy And then and then you and then you do a great job that you get great reviews and then like don't talk about Tony nominations Which is a jinx it and you got a nomination unbelievable. He's ever going to win, right? They can't give Johnny a ton of, they give him the, they give him the drama desk and the outer circles, but in the Tony's not going to get a man.
You got it. But there yours is spelled with an I, right? And it's dotted with a heart, right? I mean, it's like more of a Tony, a little bit of an award. The Tony, Tony, Tony's, Tony's, Tony's done it again. But no, that's very more of a 2020 than an award. The 2020, 2020. The 2020 is done it again. But no, that's very kind of. I think congrats, man.
That's very sweet. You guys already have showered me with so much love and praise in our texts and things. So, but thank you. And it is wild. It's wild to Jason what you just said about doing, you know, the week we shot that document, or the two weeks we shot that
doc series that's now wearing, I was trying to remember. We always see that by the way, if somebody wanted to see that, if somebody wants to do that, where would they go? It would be a max. It's max. Oh, max. That's where they find it. Sean, not only are you learning, you're, we, we, we arrived, we did those shows on the
weekend and the next day you flew to Chicago. That's right. And the next day flew to Chicago to do it, just to the last show. But Jay, you were sleeping or something and I had to wheel to run lines with me. Yeah. No, really.
And Will ran lines with me on the couch and I was like, yeah. It was that that's so bizarre to me. That's why they got the special, you got a certificate. I'm on the Tony, yeah, the engraved just a little spot. It just look underneath it. It says rail lines with it says.
Will's. Will get into it. But we just could not be prouder. And the fact that we've both seen it and can attest to its quality is is also well. And I you know, you get so nervous when you get up there and you receive an award and you forget to thank people and I really honestly forgot to thank to my best friends in the whole world. You guys oh wait. Why? And that would go on here and my family too. I thought I was actually taken by how together you were up there with
that. I was like, Rick, how was your name? I was a red double actor because you seemed not nervous at all. I love when you said Scotty. It's Scotty, right? And you were so funny. So, Sean, and the only the only one one liner I had ready should I had won was, uh, this is going to be the first time I'm going to ask her when a Tony.
Yeah. And in the room there, eh, didn't land so well. It was like, I TV played great. So who cares about the room, right? But, but um, the right. Listen, I was watching, I was watching that thing and I was just thinking, you see all these theater people in there and they got there in the biggest night and I thought, man, this is show-based for losers.
You know? That's Will texted that. Will was texting me in real time while he was watching the Tony Awards saying, this is the first time I've ever watched the Tony Awards because of you. And you put it on. Better than when.
Better than when. But it was wild. You know, it's that also when they call your name, it's that weird thing where you watch TV your whole life, whether it's Oscars, Emmy's, Tony's, whatever, and you watch other people walk up there. And you're like, oh, that's so nice. I'm a big fan or I love that show
or that whatever, that actor. And then when you're, while I was walking up the steps, it was like, I'm not supposed to be walk. Like other people walk up the steps. That's supposed to be you. Didn't get you know. Didn't you get you to that walk with the, what is it? Half a dozen Emmys you've won.
I have one. Gold and Globes, Sag Awards, all these other things. I was just thinking, I was just thinking between us, between us, we've won a handful of golden globes and Emmys and sags and Tony. I mean, that's amazing. Isn't that what we did in the past? We did. It would be an egot group.
No, but between the three of us, we've won all these, I mean, I haven't won any of them, but you guys, and then I, but between the three of us, but you ran lines with both of us. I've run line with both of you guys, and you've both been one. So yeah, if you look at my thing, like, but, but between the three of us, but you ran lines with both of us. I've run line with both of you guys and you've both been one. So, yeah, I know, I really look at my thing. Like, yeah, technically I've never won an award, but you know, that's we won it. Hey, we all three won a webby. We did. We did. We did. How about a few of them?
We did. A few of them. Guys, thank you so much for saying that truly. Truly. Thank you for all the love and support you've shown me and the show by talking about it on the podcast. And you guys are the best. I love you. We love you.
And anyway, we had to talk about it because it was just too important. And now we can get to our regular scheduled program, which is the Fantastic Jennifer Carter episode. Can't wait. Welcome to Smart episode. Welcome to Smart List. Welcome to Smart List. Welcome to Smart List. That is very sweet, you guys.
Thank you. Seannier, are you happy that we're on day two of your days off? Yes. This is your weekend right now. Monday Tuesday is your weekend. It is Monday Tuesday and my weekend. How's your eyeball? Have you been performing?
I don't know. I'm going to go back after we're done here. I'm going to go back and see if my retinus detached. Isn't that crazy? Yeah, but did he re-stick it last week? Well, I don't know. We talked about Vasevago, right? Where he gets sick and you faint.
Yep. Yeah. He puts the anesthesia in your eye and then opens it and sticks something in your eye to keep it open. This is an eye doctor or just a fellow downstairs. It's a proctologist. This is the guy. And then he shoots lasers in your eye and it's kind of painful.
Like from the hip. Yeah, he shoots from the hip. Poo, pooo. Yeah, and he puts those star wars sounds in it to make me sooth like. He does, huh? Poo, poo, poo. Yeah, that guy's not Wars sounds in it to make me sooth. He does, huh? Pupu, pupu. Yeah, that guy's not an accredited doctor, Sean. But Sean, you've been, you've been doing the show, right?
Didn't you, what did you have like one day off or two days off with the, I have to the other thing? I have Monday's and Tuesday's off. No, no, but I mean, after you got your, your last week, yeah, you do. Yeah, I did the laser thing on Tuesday and had two shows the next day. You did seven shows after the laser thing. Yeah, I did laser thing on Tuesday and had two shows the next day. You did seven shows after the laser thing. Yeah, it was. Did you bump into any any any cast members or set decoration?
No, no set decoration. No, I did okay, but I'm supposed to bang my head, you know, when I try to get those voices out of my head. So I cut back and I just grabbed my head now. That's good. Not as good. Not as good. Do you do you feel like it might be a nice kind of homage
if eventually you end up using your mom's eye? Well, no, I'm serious because I know that Tracy's got it, right? Trace. I could use that. Trace, get it shined up. I could get, I could finally see how my mom saw. No, you're not gonna have to do that. I think you're okay. Because you made it through last week.
Well, we're gonna find, I know, I made it through. So we're gonna find out what happens today after we're done here, and then I'll let you guys know, because I'm sure you'll be on the edge of your seats. Hey, quick question, Jason. Are you wearing one of those, those sauna sweatsuits? Yeah, it looks like it. Are you trying to, are you trying to cut weight?
It's just a crappy overthrow. You have to look at the top. It's a little cloudy today. You know, speaking of Proctologist, guys, our next guest, wait, what? It's not my guest. Jamie, and you have the exact same glasses on today. And same hair.
We should start at the end. Well, the part yours in the middle. No, it's not meant to be in the middle. It really isn't. You know, I look like a water yak when it goes. Well, we've been through what it looks like in profile when it's just the outline. Yeah. On the smartless logo, I look like a dickhead. Yeah. A literal dickhead. But let's not. By the way, let's talk about our FaceTime last night. Well, for two seconds, FaceTime is on it? Was I on it?
No. And he, literally, never seen any human being eat this fast. He's talking, he's talking, he's talking while I'm talking to him. He's making a sandwich. Maybe 30 seconds later, the entire sandwich is gone. It's a ham and cheese sandwich gone like that. Was it a small size bread or something? No.
It was a big, full size bread? Yeah, big sandwich. I just hammered it in like four bites. And then he went on a hike. I needed fuel to go on your hike. You know, and I went on a hike. Did you put on, did you strap on the heavy hands and the heavy ankles and walk up the hills?
Yeah, I wore the weight vest. And did you zip into the rubber suit? I wish. Do you ever talk on your hike while you zip into the rubber suit? Do you ever do you ever talk on your hike while you're on the phone? Do you ever pass anybody? Wait, what kind of question is that? Meaning like when you're walking and do you talk to people on your hike because I don't like it when people are like, so I'm I do sometimes what are you doing tonight? And I'm like just calm me when you're done. All the role calls, I'll roll call sometimes.
What if you got one of those, you know, they use them for motion capture where you get where the helmet with the camera that's looking back at you. You could do face times while you're walking. You could do face time. Yeah. But you know what I mean when people are like talking to you.
I do, of course I do. I'm that guy. And what happens is also is that that street is, I will have, and you don't always look the best because it's quite straight uphill and you get quite tired. Jay, we've done it before together. And remember Amanda's mom used to do it every day.
And people go like, yeah, man, I saw you out there the other day. I'm like, thinking like, I just looked like a sweaty slob that was off and then puffed and I didn't know. I didn't know. And on a weekday. Actually, you saw me there a couple of weeks ago. You pulled over. Yeah.
Yeah. But you pulled over. You didn't know it was me. You thought I was just a hot guy. Yeah. Walking up the hill. That's what you said. Hey, hot guy. And then you saw me.
What I mean? Ha ha. Hey, well, Hi, guy. Hi, guy. Instead of a guy. Hi, guy. Hi, guy.
Um, this, our guest is a really quick. Sorry. Yeah, go ahead. I guess our guest is a fun time. No, no, just really quick. One of the most embarrassing moments of my entire life, I was driving off the NBC lot. This is decades ago. And there was this really good looking guard. And I rolled out in front of my, I was in the car with me.
And I looked back just as I passed him, and I went like that. And the guard, I noticed the guards saw me do that. And all of him and the five other guards were laughing so hard because I knew it was me that checked him out. It was so embarrassed. That's my story. Oh, we always need something to cut.
Will, if you're going to want to cut that. All the way there in no destination. I tell you, you never guess cut. Oh, great. Is our guest today? This person is not going to get, because you're going to want to see this. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful.
I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I tell you, you never guess cut. Oh, great. Is our guest today? This person is not gonna get, because you're gonna wanna see this person, and the people who hire this person want this person to be in every frame of everything they do. Because this is somebody who's been in many frames for many years. This is a person who's done, it really run the gamut.
Started in New York, first professional job was an understudy. The queen. Yeah, and then moved into TV, did the whole thing, paid or dues in TV, guest stars on all the biggest shows and pilots and shows that lasted three episodes and six episodes. And then got a show that clicked
in the biggest way. I got it. It's not friend-dressure. Clicked in the way that people just loved and couldn't get enough of. And guess what happens when you do that? People start saying we need to put you into our film and boy did she start doing films.
Big, huge commercial films. Big, huge, a war-d nominated in winning films. This person has done it all. You're not saying anything. All while being the mom to three kids and maintaining a consistency over time, which is really the mark of somebody who's incredible. Guys, I haven't given it away yet,
but you know her from Alias, I hadn't given it away yet, but you know we're from Alias, you loved her in Daredevil, you knew her in Pearl Harbor. You like her in the estate? It's Jennifer Garner. See, Jen Garner? Oh, look at her.
Oh, that's it. She's back up. She's back up. Look at her. Hello. I usually have a baseball, okay, wait a minute. Jennifer Garner. Yeah, you always have a hat on. I usually have a baseball, okay, wait a minute. Jennifer, go ahead.
Yeah, you always have a hat on. I always do. I always do. Yeah. You and Jason have the exact same glasses frames on right now. Listener, we've had a lot of nice people on this show. Sure. None is nice, is Jen.
Babe, man, I'm so happy to see you. Hi, guys, I got so nervous. Do people get nervous when you're about to introduce them? No, I have. I have a runny tummy right now. Always. Well, that's not, uh, people do, I think that, I don't know if people get nervous, but, but I think that nervous are always a good sign.
Okay, great. I mean, you're a real person. You're a great set. It means that you're in the moment. Uh, hi, Jennifer Garner. We've never met before. I know. That is so weird to me because I really remember you from the Venice moment. Hi, Jennifer Garner, we've never met before. I know, that is so weird to me,
because I really remember you from the Venice days and the whole, yeah, your whole compound. Yeah, the whole, I was in the compound with everybody who was in your show. What, you guys have never met? What compound? I know, it's not weird. When I was living out with Bradley,
Bradley and I were in the back in Bon Rift and Iva. And Ron and Iva were in the front. Yeah. Where were you, John? How could you never meet if you guys were that close? when I went in the back in Ron and Iva. And Ron and Iva were in the front. Yeah. Where were you, Jen? How could you never meet if you guys were that close? I would kind of skulk around to try to avoid them. But you were living in the same building, Jen? No, no, I wasn't.
It's just like Ron and Iva, Ron Riscan and his wife were in one part of this compound. And Ron was on Ilius. He played Sloan and Bradley Cooper was there. Right. And so, so when transpo was driving the van in the morning, picking up all the cast members, you're surprised. Oh, you might have seen this show. I don't know. It wasn't that kind of, this is sometimes
they saw Will taking out the garbage, but yeah, by the way, I didn't take out the garbage. That's why Ron got mad at me. Do you know that story? No, but I'm not surprised. I thought that's why you brought it up. I don't want Ron Riftkin running after Ron. I used to we were, I guess we're going to rest the development of the time. And I was never there for singing the morning on Monday, whatever it was or Thursday mornings. And at this point, Bradley moved out and Robbie Bates had moved into Bradley's place. Right, right, right.
Right. So Robbie was there and I go and all of a sudden like, Rob is kind of, I go, I think Ron's mad at me because I haven't taken the trash out because I don't get it. Why is it your job? It was anybody's job, whoever could do it. But Ron would do it right at 5 p.m. The moment you're allowed to put it out the night before you would put it out. And I'm like, I didn't get home till 7 a.m. at a clock from work.
So I think he's mad at me and Robbie's like, oh, you're reading into it. You're being crazy. I'm like, okay. And like two months later, who was it who I saw? I saw somebody. And they said to me, oh, I ran, I ran into Ron Riftkin at a party and he says that you never take the trash out. I said, I knew it. And they said to me, oh, I ran into Ron Riftkin at a party and he says that you never take the trash out. I said, I knew it. And I said to Robbie, I'm like, who's crazy now? All right. If we don't cut me-
You don't want that story? I'm checking out the NBC guard. You don't want the Ron Riftkin trash or your- People just run into it in double time. See, Jen, there's nothing to be nervous about. We don't let you get a word in edgewise. I know. It's like talking-
It's Jennifer Garner, everybody. Yeah. so we don't let you get a word in as well. I know, just like talking. It's Jennifer Garner, everybody. Finally, you're the most delicious person. You're a so sweet and kind. What's with the 1950s microphone? I don't know, this just came. You're lovely guys, sonnet. We sent it over.
So Jennifer Garner, and I was, again, can I call you Jen? Yeah, unless you're gonna use the whole thing. I mean, does anybody call you Jenny? Not very few people. There's a first-day D that I love who calls me Jenny. Like people like that, just random people in my life, but I never mind, but.
Well, you call Aniston Jenny sometimes. I always find it very cute. I think it's very affectionate. Yeah. I like Jenny as a nickname for Jen. Yes. In a weird way, but I didn't grow up as a Jenny. But I bet Jen Aniston would agree with me that we, you know, why weren't we named like
Savannah or Ireland or something? Well, I also call Jason, I also call your wife Mandy. Nobody else calls her Mandy, but I like her. But, but so Jen, I want to go, I want to go way back because I love your, I love your trajectory. It's so great. And I mentioned it in the lead in when I was reading about you that all the frames. Yeah, well, I also, I felt very similar in that like I could,
when I looked at all the stuff that you did and the shows that got canceled in the three episodes and this stuff, that was my pain for so many years as well. You had all these near miss and you think like, oh, this is though, I'm so excited about this show. And then before you know it. Yeah, this is the one before you know, and JB, you know what it's like too. Oh my God.
All of a sudden it's gone. And you're like, what? I remember, I did a movie, my first like movie movie was Mr. McGoo with starring Leslie Nielsen as Mr. McGoo. Oh my God, remember that. Sure you do. I do. And when it was coming out, I knew so little
that I thought, well, I guess I get to go to the Oscars this year because I'm in a movie. I seriously was like, well, I guess. I get to dress. I better I guess. I better get ready. I better go shopping. Is it true that Leslie Nielsen, every day of his life, walked around with a little fart machine in his pocket?
He did. There was a fart machine. Yeah. I think that's so awesome. That'd be good. There's also this guy and I can't remember who it was. Or there wasn't a machine, but there was farting. Oh boy.
There was another. There was another. I was gonna say, Jay doesn't need a machine. There's a guy, I feel like it's not Jeffrey Tambor, but it's somebody like that equally hilarious that, oh, his bit, his whole life is to walk around with a little bit of loose change in his pocket and he just drops it as he walks by people. Right? What's his, what's his, what's his, because you can't help but go, oh, sir, you, you know, like, you just keep walking.
You just drop and you change. It's a great tip. It's a great tip. So, first, so you're shopping for the Oscars after Mr. McGue, Happy Birthday to another great bit. Just say that, like, in an elevator. I don't know. Sorry, Willie.
So, you're ready to go to the Oscars after Mr. McGoo. What was the thing? What had you done before Mr. McGoo? You had done a bunch of shows before then? What was the first... And by the way, weren't you with theater nerd too? Yeah, I was a theater nerd. Well, let's go back then. Well, let's go back and...
Let's go back. You started as a... You weren't a theater major to begin with, is that true? Correct, I was a chemistry major. Wow. Wow. Do you have that kind of the brain that loves that still? No, no, no. I don't think I had it then. I just think my dad was a chemical...
He's a retired chemical engineer, think my dad was a chemical engine. He's a retired chemical engineer and I come from a chemistry town. Like it was Union Car by Dow, DuPont. Yeah, there are like five people left knowing I really do have a like a drinking water must be delicious. It's all different colors. Rainbow players. Sure. Do you have a sci-fi brain though that you that you do like sci-fi, because of alias and all that, or no? No. Mm-mm. No, well, you don't have to be that.
No, I'm just thinking. Like, you would think that, but no, I just... Your girls aren't taking chemistry yet. Are they Franny's taking chemistry? I don't know, she's doing it. Oh my gosh, my daughter's a junior. Yes, so then she is. Yes, she's done with chemistry.
Yeah, how old are yours? For any 16 and Maple is 11. Oh, wow. Okay, I have 16, 14 and 11. Are you helping out with chemistry at all? No, no, no. No, you didn't retain any of it. I don't remember.
I mean, truly, I can't help with that homework of my high school junior. Not even, I can hardly read it. What about math? What about math? What about math? She had her AP, my heart, BC, Calc, AP, whatever, her exam yesterday. That's just, yeah, definitely.
Definitely. Derived it, like I don't even, when's the last time you dealt with a parabola? You know what I mean? Well, today, I feel like we really shouldn't have to do it. Jason, I haven't seen you in a long time. I know. You know?
Remember when we used to work together, like once every eight or nine months? Yeah, remember when we were together all the time? You guys did Juno? We did Juno. What else? But before that, we did the Kingdom. Well, you did the Kingdom, of course.
Was Kingdom before Juno? Kingdom was before Juno. Didn't we do a third thing together? We did, and I always forget, and I actually looked it up because we didn't have scenes together. That's why. Oh, it was a Ricky Jervais. It was invention of lying, yes.
Yes, yes. Oh, I love that movie. Yeah. And now, a word from our sponsor. Everybody, please join me with a big thank you. Does it precrooter for their support? Without zipper cruder, it would be hard to do this. What would be really helpful, though, if they could get us,
if they could, if they're listening, I'd like to get Howard Stern on the show, if they can help us out there, or about Barack Obama. That would be fantastic. Please, zipper cruder, you're fantastic. You're doing what you do. Do it for us, please. Because after all, it is hard to turn down
a personal invitation. So just imagine if you're hiring, and you could send a personal invitation to the top candidates for your job. Well, now you can. With Zippercruder's invite to apply feature. And right now, you can try Zippercrooder for free at zippercrooder.com slash smartless.
How does Zippercrooders invite to apply feature work? Well, first, Zippercrooders technology finds and sends you the most qualified candidates for your job. Then you can review this curated list and invite the ones you're really interested in to apply to your job at the click of a button. And when you send out personal invites to your favorite candidates, it lets them know that they're one of your
top choices and they'll be more likely to apply. Invite Zippercrooter to be your hiring platform. Four out of five employers who post on Zippercrooter get a quality candidate within the first day, everybody. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zipper Cruder 4 free, zippercruder.com-smartless. Again, that's zippercruder.com-slash-smartless is sponsored by BetterHelp. Now, I play some golf, and sometimes golf is very calming for me.
It's sort of, it is my help, but sometimes it's not calming, sometimes it's infuriating. I need tools to balance my life sometimes, And therapy, I guess, could give me those tools to find more balance in my life. And maybe that could work for you too. So you can keep supporting others without leaving yourself behind. It's worked for me. When I'm in a good place, I can be good for other people. Better help can help you be the best you can be so you can, you know, share a little of that surplus with other folks. So if you're
thinking about starting therapy, give better help a try. It's entirely online. It's designed to be convenient, flexible, and it's suited to your schedule. You just fill out this brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists at any time for no additional charge. Find more balance with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com-smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com-smartless. This episode is supported by FX is the bear.
The hit series returns with Jeremy Allen White in the Golden Globe winning role of Karmie. He and the team will transform their family sandwich shop into a next level spot all while being forced to come together in new ways as they confront their past and reckon with who they want to be in the future. FX is the bear, all episodes streaming streaming June 22nd only on Hulu. And now back to the show. So you become a theater nerd, you're at Dennis and you switch majors, you don't want to become
a glenjonier, you become, you're working on the sets, you're doing all this stuff, you know, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then what? You're like, all right, I graduate, I'm out of here and I'm gonna go and work all the time. Okay, so then I worked at a Shakespeare Festival in Atlanta, Georgia, the summer after I graduated. And while we were there, there was a musical,
because I really, I loved musicals. And there was a musical, a new version of what's it called? Taming of the Shrew. Okay. Okay it called, Taming of the Shrew. Okay. Okay. What is Taming of the Shrew is the name of the, which is Kiss Me Kate, there's Kiss Me Kate, but apparently there needed to be another one.
So it was called Dancing with the One I Love. And so that show was taken to a theater in a strip mall in Fort Lauderdale, called the Brian the Brian C Smith Off-Broadway Theater. Uh-huh. And I- Uh-huh. We're still with you. This is next to TurboTax.
Right. It literally was. It was shut down for tax evasion later. Oh, no, sure. But I went down with that show and performed there. And I was there as a non-equity performer because I had been hiding from my equity card because I could work more, you know?
Yeah, right. So I was working as a non-equity performer. So I didn't have, they didn't have to put me up. So in exchange for being someone's roommate, I was in charge of the laundry for the entire cast and there were 35 men. We did eight shows a week. So I washed and ironed all there,
but I got really good at ironing. No way! Yeah, I did all of the washing drying, all of the dry cleaning. I can't touch anyone's dirty clothes. I love dirty clothes. It can't do it. I want to iron your little ponchos so bad.
And your hand goes in the wrong spot. Oh gosh. I can't be. You're gonna look for the waistband, grab that. Oh my god. Do you love that? Of all household chores you love ironing? Like do you love that?
I have a friend that loves ironing. Yeah, I got that. I got really into it at the time. I was so, I just ironed all the time. So yeah. I used to be one of my chores on the weekends. I just learned a new hack is to, if you have rings on a wood table, something like that.
And you put like a, just a damp towel on it and you iron it and it'll bring the ring mark off. Maybe you guys already got. Oh my god. I learned it on the TikTok. Hey, so listen. You tube shorts. Yeah, you tube shorts.
They call cute lots. So, Jen, so you're in Florida, you're doing a ton of laundry and Hollywood calls. I was doing a ton of laundry. And after it was over, I was driving North to audition for... Back to Georgia. From, yeah, I was driving up North to audition for Utah Shakespeare for the next summer.
And when I was on my way there, I met a casting director in Philadelphia at a restaurant and he said, you should come and read for this little movie. Anyway, I ended up in New York for a couple of days. And while I was there, I went on an audition. And I, actually, I opened the backstage, I went on a bunch of auditions. And because I was so green and so fresh off the bus,
like West Virginia girl, I just got everything that day that I went on. They were all these little non-equity jobs. It was just one of those days, you know? It's just like, it's my first day in New York, hi. I'd hire you right now based on this interview. It's unbelievable, right? So somebody said you should meet an agent.
I met this agent. She said, I want to send you to the roundabout to see if you could get an understudy job. And so anyway, then I did. And then I started working at Isabella's. Do you remember Isabella's on the southeast corner of 77th Street and Columbus Avenue? Yes, that's a bar. Yes of 77th Street and Columbus Avenue? Yes.
That's a bar. Yes, I do. Yeah, restaurant. Yeah, it was across from the Natural Museum of History. Yes, I know Isabella's. Yeah. Do you ever get loaded in there, Will? I sure did.
But that was a different life time. So how quickly after that were you back on the bus out to Hollywood? A few years. Because I only wanted to do theater. Right. And you have this amazing singing voice that not a lot of people know that you have, but you do. No.
But so that was the dream to do musicals on Broadway. Never to go out to Hollywood. I mean, it was just to be in theater. I didn't really, I mean, I love dancing. I don't really have a voice that could be a professional singing voice unless it's like the range from, you know, here to here. But Broadway quality.
Yeah, I don't have like a Broadway voice, but I have a karaoke voice. We've done karaoke sort of, Fancy karaoke. But anyway, yeah, then I was super broke and I had just finally auditioned for a TV thing. This agent sent me on and she said, well, they want to test you for this. And I said, I'm understudying right now. And she said, they'll give you $150 a day cash per deum.
And I so badly needed that cash. I was so broke that I came to LA to test for something and I got that job and it was to play Melissa Gilbert's daughter in a Daniel Steel mini series. So then I did that. Oh my god. Yeah. I was up for the same part. Wow.
Wow. Melissa Gilbert was one of my first crushes. Yeah, you guys are so tied to each other because I was just thinking, Jay, you worked with Melissa Gilbert on Little House. Yes, sir. Yeah. That's right.
Things all started to happen for me. Testosterone and my career. I kept calling her Laura. I remember in here in makeup, I kept calling her Laura. Did you really? Yeah. Yeah.
She taught me everything I'd never been in front of, I'd never been in front of a camera. I'd never paid attention to any of it. She taught me what a call she was, who to talk to for things. She taught me about the camera turning around. I had no, I was totally clueless. Oh my God, that's so sweet.
That's so nice. Did you guys, did you stay connected with her at all after? Yeah, I have. You know, she's in government and politics. Yeah, I had a fundraiser for it. Yep. Married to Timothy Bussfield. Yeah, very happily.
The great Timothy Bussfield, yeah. Couple of genders. Yeah, yeah. Found each other. Well, my son's a genders, so I always have a soft spot. One of my sweet, sweet ginger. Sweetable. So you do the movie with now you've,
and then she's taught you everything you need to know about showbiz in half hour. So then I'm in. So now you're in. Then I went back to New York and I would, every time I would get some kind of play, I would be so broke. I would get an episode of Lawn Order or some dumb thing and I would take that job because I needed that top show. Well, you did Lawn order, right? I did. Scale plus 10. Scale plus 10. You're just so stupid.
But also you're working in the city. And as you, like you, like you're working in the city, you're so excited that you get to shoot in the city. And you end up like shooting on, so you're like, I was just here yesterday. Byin, milk, and now I'm here shooting at, you know what I mean? You're so crazy. Isn't it when you're're when you first or drive or
Going up somewhere and you see like you know big caravans and whole set in a base camp and you're like wow There's a movie shooting there and you're like wait a minute. That's me. Yeah, do you remember that? Yeah, I still feel that way I still get that way up don't drive in up to location and just seeing all the trucks Yeah, yeah Because I remember like moving to Los Angeles for the trucks. It's like, yeah. Yeah, because I remember like moving to Los Angeles for the first time seeing that and like just waiting tables and you're like, that'd be so cool. What are they filming over there?
I'd love to be a part of it. Yeah. How did, so, so right off the bus from West Virginia, you're in New York, you're very green. How did that, how, how did you find the city? Was it, was it scary or did you adapt immediately? I was pretty happy. I mean, I just, I really went right into it. I just would pay my $20 to stand at the back of the Broadway
house to watch every show that I could by myself like this. And I would go to museums. And I mean, I just was nerding out. So you weren't going to the discos in the bars in the... No, it wasn't doing any of that. But my mom always told me that the more people you make eye contact with and smile at during this day on the street, like strangers,
the happier you are as a person. So, oh, the cuckoo clocks, right? But so as I was walking down... Does that go off every time you caught having cuckoo your mom said? Yes, it would be very busy. Wait, why it? Wait, by the way, by the way,
there's a, that was Kuku. There's a lot of wisdom in that, because I like that your mom said that, and I was just listening to a thing today, because it is, it lends itself to the Kuku Plexi Maltes. We get locations on the Kuku Plexi. Yeah, I wish Melissa Gilbert had told you about the sound of the roller.
I got to deal with that. Kuku. So there's a lot of wisdom in that. I like this idea that it's kind of, you know, you get what you put out there. And so, and I think that that's true. If you go out and you make eye contact and you smile at people and you kind of, you project joy, you're going to get joy coming back anyway. Yeah, right.
Okay, but when you first moved to New York, Well, that's crazy. Yeah, that is very hard on the population of New York. I was very tiring. I was like, hi, hi, how you doing? Nice day. I like your shoes. I mean, it was a lot.
I was, I was a lot. Well, you can't compliment people's shoes in New York. But, but when you're, where was your first apartment? Do you remember what part of the city? Yeah. I lived on a woman's kitchen floor on 85th and Broadway. Wow. She had a studio, but the kitchen was kind of its own alcove
and I had a little futon and my suitcase for nine months. Wow, like a puppy. What year was that? Yeah, a puppy. A puppy. 94. OK. Why were you on 85th and? No, I lived on, I lived on 87th and West What you was actually thinking. What you were, 94. Okay. Why were you on 85th and?
No, I lived at 87th in West End with five other people. That was like 90, 91. And then by 92, I was living on the upper east side in a railroad apartment with two other two. I'm on, Jen, I'm on 81st and Broadway right now. Oh, no way. No, I don't care. Wait, so.
So, that's a nice apartment. Is that your apartment? Yes, brand new. And only does is watch TV in there. Yeah. So, so you do this. Now you're living there, you're living in New York and you're doing some, you're doing law and order,
you're doing Spin City, kind of go back and watch your Spin City episode. Yeah, you do. I'm shocked that you haven't. I know, I know. And then, where does Aliess fall into all of this? Like, I'm well sorry, you meet JJ Abrams because you do Felicity.
Yes, so a few years go by, and I had been working probably seven years by the time I met JJ and did Felicity and Alias. And how'd you meet JJ? I just auditioned for Felicity for a guest spot. Oh, gotcha. Wow. And then it was like you remember, do you?
But I had heard and JJ is a friend of the show. So he's listening. I had heard that you, that he wrote Alias with you in mind. He did. I know, it's not cool. He gave it to me and I stood in one spot in my kitchen and read the pilot. I didn't even move. I was so, it was still, I think it's the best pilot.
I think. That's awesome. He's such an incredible director too. Yeah, it turned out. Yeah, it's such a great, it is a great pilot. And it was, and it was a, it was a great show and you're great on it and. I think it's his general energy. I mean, it is a great pilot. And it was, and it was a, it was a great show and you're great on it. And, um,
I think it's his general energy. I mean, it's pretty infectious. It's so positive. Yeah. He gives you his full attention. Is super sincere? I just, but there's not a lot like that. And is that where you met our lovely Victor Garber
that we have in common? Yes. That is where I met our lovely Victor Garber. Although I'd been a big fan of his, I'd seen him in art, I'd seen him in the one with Billy Cruda, that started with an A at Lincoln Center. I'd, you know, the one I'm talking about.
Yeah, Arcadia. Arcadia, thank you. Yeah, whenever we have dinner, whenever Victor and I got to dinner, he's a very close friend of both yours and mine. Mm-hmm. And all of a... He was at a premier party.
Or you're opening your... Yes, he was at the premier. Opening party or you're opening. Yes, or is that the opening night and Any time we go out to dinner, I'll always say super super loud. Oh my god. Were you in Titanic? And everybody looks and he's Is everyone's looking for Leonardo DiCaprio. Did you guys see him in God's Bell? Yes, Martin Short and and every other Canadian actor That's all. Is everyone's looking for Leonardo DiCaprio? Did you guys see him in God's Bell? Yes. With Martin Short and every other Canadian actor
that we've had on the show. Every Canadian actor. And they're all still super close, that entire cast. I know it. Really, it's like 40 years later. I love that. Wait, am I showing my dumbness by wondering why would they all be Canadians?
It all really started. There was, like, so God Spell was this thing on Broadway. It was a huge sensation. Wait, wait, Jen, Jen, before I hate to interrupt you, but I have to, Jason, we've had at least five members of that production on the podcast who have talked about the fact that they were all in that production.
No recollection at all. I just thought maybe God Spell was written by a Canadian. It's a Canadian story and no. Yeah, Jesus, Jesus turns out was a Canadian. Everyone knew it. So, do you see this as in Godspell? Oh my God. Oh my God.
Godspell's not one word. There's two words. How do you spell? How do you spell God? So, so, G-A-W-D. Oh my God. Vector, and you know, I used to see Victor too
back in the alias days. Through Bradley. Yeah. By the time, yeah. Yeah, and we would have dinner out on the west side with that little me and the rest of the cast of alias all the time,
because Bradley was on alias. Mm-hmm. I felt like a sort of an eighth member of the cast, if you will. No, you won't. You won't. No, you won't. So, so, Ali's comes about, and then I remembered the time when Ali's came out, and it was so good,
and it was so kickass, and there was so much written about. First of all, you were the lead of this show, and you were kickass lead, too. Yeah. Like, you just kind of, it's like you were shot out of a cannon and you were beaten fools up and knocking people out and crotch-hopping heads and doing shit and like all this spy stuff. And I remember the stories about you, your training regiment and how insane it was at the time. I still think about it to this day sometimes.
I'm going to admit to you something. I think about it sometimes when I think about getting up and working out before work and I'll think about you, the stories of you are embedded in my mind and I don't know you working out before doing alias. I swear to God. That is really. Wait, you would work out before shooting 12 hours a day? Yeah, I would because, Wait, you would work out before shooting 12 hours a day? Yeah, I would, because Carl Lumley, who was on the show, I started saying like, it's so hard for me to keep a workout. Our hours were so insane and I said,
and I need to be warmed up and I just can't seem to get it all done. And he is such a state league, gorgeous man. And a theater actor and somebody I just respect so much. And at the time, like I had all these, I'd run, I had Victor, and I'd Carl all on the show. So I was looking up to them so much for anything. And Carl said, you can always do half an hour. You just set your clock, just get up and do it.
You can always do it. And so from that day, I was just like, oh, okay, then I will. And so just no matter what, I would crank my clock earlier to REE 45. You know, I would do anything to show up to work warmed up because there was so much action and I never, I didn't know when things were gonna happen
and I just, I wanted to be ready for whatever. Now I don't do that. And now, like a six and an occasional five, but I don't, you know, not really. But isn't it depressing how much harder it is to stay in shape as we get older? I mean, it's almost like it doubles the amount of time you have to spend at it almost every year. I remember you solidly running six or seven miles every day. Never it never helped.
Never helped. It's still a running like I'm being chased. I also remember you spinning upside down in a car and just. And then you I remember you who were you pregnant with when you threw up? Was it violent? No, you already had violence. I was I was nursing. That was the issue.
It was so hot where we were shooting the kingdom. Like we were in Arizona and it was August and September and 120 on asphalt. And we were wearing big boots and hats and bulletproof vests. And we, I went, that's the only time knock on wood. I've ever had to go to the hospital during shooting. I would get so dizzy, I couldn't see. I was nursing, I should have, you know. No way.
But I see, but on your Instagram, I see like you working out all the time. It's so inspiring. Like first of all, what, your mom, you work constantly, you work out, you're doing all these things. I see you do so many things. Like, is there, I asked this question a lot
because I find it fascinating. Is there a thing or a person that inspired you to be ambitious and to have this drive? Like where does that come from? To just do all of these things. I don't know, but don't you feel like you get older and you look around and there are people you admire and just like that moment with Carl?
Like something just like makes you realize, oh, I can do that. I can reach for that. I can go harder. I can reach for, I can go harder. I can reach for that. I can be more. Yeah, why not you? Jen, you're my curl.
That's what I'm trying to tell you. Oh, good. I'm so glad. I'll see you at, let's set the alarm. Let's face time. You could join me. But when you were younger, was there like a family member or a person where you just like something clicked in your head and you're like, wait a minute,
I like how they live their life. I like how they kind of make the decisions they've made. I mean, I don't know, I have pretty great parents. Like they just, yeah. I'm pretty great, yeah. Do you find that your children are as motivated as you were at that age? They are, each of them in their own ways.
The hard thing is that you think it's gonna be your ways. And their ways are things I could never do and are they're amazing, but they are not, they keep forgetting to be me. Yeah. Yeah. Well, they, because it is fun. Do you find, well, Sean, do you find your dad? Oh, period. Sorry, sorry, that was just it. Just that one question. Sorry, sorry. Nobody is funny watching our kids, and this kind of goes out to everybody.
Like watching our kids have go about it in a different way than we went about it. Yeah. And I constantly find myself wanting to say like, hey, man, maybe if you, and then I'm just going, no, no, no, no, it's okay. He's going to do it his own way. I can, I'm just here to kind of act as bumpers on either side to keep them within a certain range.
Well, that's interesting though, because my, because of the way I was, we were raised in my dad and left early that old story, because of that, my two brothers who have kids are phenomenal dads. Wow. They're amazing. Yeah. I mean, it doesn't always go that way though. That's right, but I mean, that was the inspiration to be a great dad.
Can I tell you something that happened the other night that I found really nice. I was with Jason and Amanda and Maple, who's 11 now, Maple, right? Yeah. And we were just talking about something and Maple was so honest and comfortable in this way and whatever. We all spend a lot of time. So when she told you to shut your mouth, when she said shut your your your stupid mouth, your stupid Canadian mouth. Yeah, you were saying something dumb. And I've been trying to keep from her that I'm Canadian for a long time. No, but she said, we started talking about something
and she was really candid with you guys and with us in this way that felt that I really, I kind of loved, it was such a reflection of you and Amanda and I love seeing that in kids when they feel this level of comfort to share and be able to speak openly. I think that's so important. That's really rare. And it was, and it was, it was really heartwarming. Yeah. Well, that's nice.
Yeah. Thank you for saying that. I'm always surprised how little children really take from the parents. This whole question of nature versus nurture. And I think I've hammered this one before. But, you know, for whenever somebody says something nice about my kids, I just might instinctively deflect anyway. But I do think it is them, it is nature, it's not nurture. I think you can affect your kid probably 5% left or right,
you know, but for the most part, you get what you get. Cause like, you know, Jen, I'm sure you've got, you've got three to compare against. I've only got two where they're same parents, same, same roof, same upbringing, and they're wildly different. So there it is. You know, it's, it's, so it's not an answer. And from the minute they were born too, like their personalities were already intact. That's why I don't have kids. I don't want to wake up in the middle of the night and have them killing me. Right.
Yeah, exactly. You could have an axe murder and you'd have nothing to do with it. You know what I'm saying? You should have recognized that if he had other that they would want to kill him. And I think that is a great room. But, Jen, what do you find now that we're on this?
What do you find challenging as a parent? And I know the list is long, because I have three kids as well. But doing what you do, and again, our jobs are not, lots of people have very busy jobs, no matter what it is you do. If you work in an office or you work outside or whatever it is you do.
But what are the challenges that you find? Our job is just a selfish job, honestly. Yeah. It's really, it's not, even in the best of circumstances, we're really, like, well, it's all about me right now. I'm in production and I've got to go to bed or I've got to, I can't be there because my production, this, my, you know, and it's like, that doesn't, that's not the way and the travel. And that's not the way kids' lives work. If something is happening
for them, it's happening for them. And you're missing it. And that's basically it. So there's so much, I mean, there's so much challenging, like teenagers and what they all have to absorb and go through. And you know, like when I go to my kids' schools and I'm there, I have three kids at three schools. And when I go and I see the energy swirling around and the kids chattering and arguing and back and forth and what's important and struggling for hierarchy, I just think, oh my gosh, it's so exhausting. I forget what they've been through by the time they come home every day.
Right, yeah. What do you do about the social media stuff? This goes out again to everybody. But Jen, what do you do about the social media stuff with your kids? Because I find it challenging. Well, so far. And I say, because it feels like there's judgment
inherent in what I'm saying. And there isn't. It's just so far, I have not, I don't have kids on social media, like, traditional Instagram TikTok, all that stuff. I don't know totally everything they're on. So, you know know I could be totally wrong. Yeah there's some work around there. There are plenty of work
arounds but they're not checking for likes and they're not posting themselves and I think you know you rules are very different for your first than they are for your third. So don't hold me to it, but that is kind of my goal. I just say to them, guys, show me the evidence that it's good for a teenage brain. Just show it to me. And then some people say, well, my kids really, that's how they converse, they converse over,
snap chatter, whatever. So far, I've been able to avoid it. And we'll just keep down that, and Ben and I are on the same page about it. We'll just keep down that road as best we can. Yeah, we're trying for the same thing or sort of a limited version. That's rare. Of at all. I want to go back to, first of all,
because one of my stock questions, the theater, I need a terrible theater story that you have, like a favorite horrible, something that went wrong, or a horrible set that something happened on a set. Mostly theater stories. He's just looking at check boxes. Or any kind of personal tragedy.
Any sort of person, big regret, something embarrassing. No, I like, I think theater stories, theater stories get go wrong or hysterical. On earth trauma would be super relatable. So, I mean, I run when I, like, I basically my instinct, I just have a lot of, and so I'd run on to stage, or I run, you know, like I just do.
So I was doing Cirono at the Richard Rogers with Mr. Klein, Kevin Klein. It was heaven, it was wonderful. But I got into a spell where I fell at some point every night. And the backstage was this huge staircase that was like two stories straight down, fully exposed. And I would come like, look, look, look, look, look, like really fast, it was so fun.
So I go, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, and the last 10 steps, go, go, go, go, on the elbow, or I would fall in the fifth act, or I'd fall at the curtain call. I just, once I started, I couldn't get my feet back under me, and people would say to me, hey, I saw you in Sierra. Oh, man, you were amazing. You know, I was there the night you fell. And it felt like, you know, you should've.
Did you start start padding up? I should have. You know when like, when stunt doubles take a stair fall and they're like, well, I put a powder puff under my wig. Now, did you end up coming up with a funny line at the bottom of your tuck and roll every night? No, because it was so serious.
You can't. You know, you just have to. It's so serious. Oh my god. It's serious. You're a no- know, you just have to do it. It's so serious. Oh my God. It's serious. It's serious. You're a no-yous. I want to know about, Jen, I love you mentioned Kevin Klein.
He's one of those guys that I've always admired and think is so great. What was that? I've never come close to the guy. And I'm just, I don't think any of us have. Have you guys ever seen him out? Never. Not once.
And I lived in New York for 20 years. I've never saw him. He lives way up on the upper east side. He's still, he's married to Phoebe. I've seen him out. Never. Not once. And I lived in New York for 20 years. I've never saw him. He lives way up on the upper east side. He's still, he's married to Phoebe. Kate, they are. Yeah, yeah. They are.
They are, they're like king and queen of their neighborhood. He has a big show on Apple coming out, I think, that they shot in London. Anyway, he is the most literate. He's one of those people that is just always taking in art. He's always reading. He's always a play in his back pocket or something. He's always taking in poetry and using it as a reference and it makes you kind of panic.
Yeah, you gotta go around the show. Of course he is. No wait, he's my idol. So wait, Jen, with everything that you've done, everything that you've accomplished, is there something, is there a role or a thing or something, you're like, you know what? I've always wanted Blank, I've never gotten on it.
I still want it. This was kind of, guys, you know, I'm a friend of the pot. I'm, yeah. Sure. This is not it, I'm a listener. Oh, guys, when you had that Simon Simon. Lebon? Lebon from Dreddredd.
That was cool. Yeah, he's very cool. He's very cool. Like Chris Farley, Senator Night Live talk show. And when you guys had, I went and ran on. That was cool.
No, you know what, when my kids go to college, I keep, you know, I feel like it's healthy to have something you're looking forward to besides just panicking. So, I think I wanna go to New York and try to be, you know, there's always like
a little lady and a musical. You know, that's my dream. When the girls go to college, it's time to go to New York and try theater. Do it. Yeah. I'll see you there. What do you wanna do?
I'll do it together. We'll you want to do? I'll do it. Let's do it together. We'll just do a little start with love letters. Great. Right? Sean, is that the question? Why don't you reimagine the odd couple as just a girl and a guy instead of a guy?
I'm not rap a poet. Rap a poet. We could call Pete Burke. He could direct us. Direct us in the odd couple. Could you imagine? It becomes War of the direct us. Direct us in the odd couple. Could you imagine? It becomes a war of the roses. We blow up the whole stage.
Totally. Yeah. So, when did you do the app, sorry, this switch? When did you do the Apple TV, your limited series that you produced, too? Uh, uh, uh, you're a go right now. I was in production. The last thing he told me, the last thing he told me out now on Apple TV, plus, it's out now. Yes, it is out right now I was in production. The last thing he told me. The last thing he told me out now on Apple TV Plus. It's out now.
Yes, it is out right now. We shot it a year ago here in LA with a sometime in Austin and sometime in Sosolito. How'd you like Austin? I love Austin. Austin's just, what a beautiful city. It's so cool. I'm pretty cool. And then you have the, everyone's drawn to the lake and.
It's so nice. Sorry, I just got to say just because I keep Austin weird Anyway Getting paid by the Chamber of Commerce there people used to have those bumper stickers. I mean, I'm really dating myself as an old It was poor. They yeah, they still the bumper stickers are still a thing Yeah, good callback great job. I'm so old. Yeah, I'm such an old All my musicals. I'm just like realizing I'm old Jen do any of the kids want to want to go into this business Have you ever got a sense of it?
I think we may have one but I don't know if that child knows it yet So I'm not gonna and how do you feel about that? Will you be encouraging if and when the light shines on him or her? What about you, Jason? What are you gonna do? I know, I feel like Franny, Franny's starting to get interested in directing, which is really exciting to me.
That's really great. So we're like watching movies together and talking about all that stuff, it's kind of like my dad and I were. I know, just like about a year ago, right? Are you a little bit of a Franny? Yeah, yeah, Franny's like, Maple dad and I were. I know, just like about a year ago, right? Are you a friend of the same thing? Maple, I think, is interested maybe in acting, but neither one is like, you know, frothing at the mouth, super passionate about it.
I'm not a big fan of kids going into this business only because you could spend all of that time studying for a career where if you're the best at it, you're guaranteed employment. You know, and this is not that. Any form of the arts part in the term, it's also objective. So I don't know, it's tough. It's a tough business to make a big deal. You can't certainly can't say no if they become adults. And that's, you know. Correct. Yeah, I'll be encouraging if they're overwhelmed with desire for it. But kids acting, little kids on set, I don't know. Well, that's the other weird part for me too, it's sort of heady where you try to train yourself
to be other people at a time when you're learning who you are. Yeah. And it's kind of heady found. Yeah. It would kind of messed me up a little bit. Yeah. And never thought of that. It's very done a little bit later, I think.
Do you feel like sometimes you're like, am I a werewolf? Am I a werewolf or something? Yeah, listen, when I don't shave, when I don't shave every other day, it just start to let my nails grow. Yeah. Yeah, and it just scraped away.
Yeah, no, it is a little schizophrenic definitely But um, thanks for bringing it down. Yeah She also told so that we're going down the technotaro highlight reel She just told the story great story the other day. She went to a party a bunch of people she didn't know to take me to our highlight reel. She just told the great story of the other day. She went to a party of a bunch of people she didn't know. And she came out on the second story balcony and she just screamed downstairs to a bunch of party goers
and she didn't know they didn't order. She just said, hey guys, sorry, excuse me. Hi, yeah, up here. I just want you guys to know I'm going to bed in like 10 minutes, okay? And then she just went back into the upstairs. Okay. And everybody's like looking at each other.
She, she, her friend, was she in her friend? Who is she talking about? She and her friend were doing what they call party bits. And she agreed to go to this party into the, into this house of somebody she didn't know. And she would walk into the kitchen and just kind of like slap the wall and go like, Hey guy, they're like six people. Because, hey guys, I'm probably going to turn it in about 10 minutes. And they're all like, okay, by the way, such a fucking God, Sean, how fun is that?
That is such a good bit. What are the other bits? I want to know where it goes. I want to do the thing when I want to drive around all the fancy neighborhoods in Los Angeles, like Beverly Hills and Bel Air and then like drive up to like cruise who were like gardening and something go, hey guys, you can knock off for the day. Yeah, and then drive and then just be like, you don't worry about, don't worry about the front guys. I talked to the guy, you guys are good to go and start wrapping cruise who are doing work.
Is it you live there? Yeah, is it if I live there? That's a good party bet. Not bad. Jen, what's the rest of your day today? You're not working on something, are you? No, I'm not working on anything. No, what is my day? I'm going to... You worked out at 3 a.m. Yeah. I worked out this morning, and actually, I actually have a boxing session after this. Oh, see. You worked out all the time. I boxed it Pete's gym. Do you really? Is he still going in there? This is Pete Berg. He still goes in there. Mm-hmm. Who's Pete Berg? Peter Berg is a is an actor director,
director, director. Oh, Peter Berg. Yeah, I was like, um, and has been, uh, has been ripped to shreds for years. Yeah. As always an incredible. Yeah. You can really box. Yeah. Yeah. Can, right? I don't get it. You can really box. I box this morning and then my 14 year old just started boxing in a gym. I'd rather play rock and talk. I remember that. Yeah. Sean, what time are you working out today? And Viana.
Look around. Look around. Look around. We. Look around. So wait, today's Tuesday. You have a shirt tonight, yeah? No, our off Mondays and Tuesdays.
So do you have two on Saturday, two on Sunday? We, we, we, we're doing seven. We're doing seven, yeah. Gosh, that's nice. Yeah, it's really, really nice, yeah. Yeah, well, what, what's normal? Eight. And, and where's the eighth show on a, on a Tuesday night?
Two, nine, two, nine. Yeah, it would, it would normally be tonight Tuesday, yeah. Yeah, but we don't, yeah. I guess it's really nice. It's really nice. It's really nice. Actually, she feels like you have a weekend. Jen, what are you in Jason? What are you in Jason? When you in Jason, do your show and Broadway when you guys moved to New York? Yeah. Let Jason get into the deal because you guys would be out four shows a week. Oh, I know. We're going
to do only Matt Nays. I heard, I don't know this truth, but I heard Dali Parton. Somebody came up to Dali Parton asked if they wanted she wanted to do some big musical camera, I don't know if they have it. And she said, sure, I'll do four shows a week. They're like, no, wouldn't you do, wouldn't you say yes to Dolly Parton doing? Yes, Dolly Parton. Go party and buy a ticket,
even if it's four shows a week. Yeah. I would buy a ticket for the show. I don't go to just to have the ticket to go to Dolly. Yeah, I don't know what she is. Did you ever go to Dollywood? Is that West Virginia? No, it's in Tennessee.
It's in Tennessee. It is so great. All the rocks have Dolly music, playing Dolly's music, everywhere you go. Rocks of speakers. The rocks have speakers. It was the first time I'd ever seen that. I was like, the rocks are singing Dolly Parton.
And I took my grandmother, Xemay, and I hoisted her up over a, like, a, a Mary go round horse. And I just, I can't believe I did it now, thinking back. Like, I'm so glad I didn't break that little lady. But Xemay was in heaven. All right. So after boxing today, where there's then, I would imagine you're going to pick up at least one of those kids. Well, yeah, I've gotta pick up some kids. I have this little company called Once Upon a Farm. Yes, yes. Yeah. So tell us what that's all about.
Wait, I don't know. Tell me about that. I don't know about that. Oh, it's actually, it's awesome. It is, it's all super clean, super organic, kids, and babies food. And it is pureed and it's cold pressed, so it's not like...
Garbage. Yeah, it's not garbage. If there's no sugar added, there's nothing added. It's just pure... I would eat all of that, but I would put the sugar in it. Yeah, sure. You would... You don't need it because it's all fresh
and it's not cooked down, so it has to be... He loves sweet and low, though. He just has sweet and low on everything. You could add a little sweet and low on everything. You put it in a blender, Sean. Sean put it in a blender, and then he't put it in a blender and then he dad, he'd add some Reese's peanut butter. What is it?
It's a sweeten a little, right? Oh, there's sweeten. Oh, that's sweet. Oh, that's good. Thanks. How are you good to see you? Sweeten a little. That's a great dick day for you.
All right, so you're gonna go and work out? So I have that stuff today. I have calls and stuff like that. All right, but wait, let's get, I want trying to get to the evening time and I want to know I like do I like asking this. What do you curl up and watch that you're a little bit embarrassed that you're watching? Yeah. Oh, well, not because it's a bad show, but just because I mean, I still watch side-felds pretty much all the time, but that's nothing to be embarrassed
about. No, just that I've seen them all a thousand. But I'm watching Diplomat. You are. Cherry Russell. Yeah, you look very nice. Oh, I heard that's really good. You look very nice. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's on the Amazon.
What's that on the Amazon? Netflix. It's on the Netflix. On the Netflix. Very nice. The kids and I are about to start jury duty. We just need to get someone in the house past AP exams and then we're gonna do a show.
I hear that's good. That's got, uh, jury duties as a show. Yeah, it's James. Marston. James Marston. James Marston, that's right. And it's really good.
It's the only one who knows what's going on and the rest all know. He's just playing himself as like a, he's playing a bratty actor. He was prepping for it. We shot party down together at the beginning of last actor. He was prepping for it. We shot party down together at the beginning of last year and he was getting ready for it. He was like, what am I going into? This is going to be a disaster and is it more is it ethically okay to be messing with this person?
And there's one person who thinks he's just part of a documentary and has no idea that everyone else isn't yeah. They just think they're on is in. Yeah, what they say is really cool. They just think I'm jury duty. He thinks that they're making documentary about this particular trial. And he's the only person and everything else is made up. Oh, wow. Doesn't know. Yeah, it's pretty cool. It's so wide. And that's good for kids, kids and adults.
I mean, I don't know that it's appropriate for kids, but I feel like my kids have probably been exposed to plenty. Even Sam's watching the R-rated movies now? My 11-year-old is at times, sometimes. Yeah, I think from time to time. Yeah, it squeaks through there. But you know what? Now, do you curse in front of the kids?
I find that I'm starting to get very, very loose with all of that. Very loose, you see? Yeah. I don't. Yeah. On purpose? Or you just don't curse at all? Do you curse a lot? You don't seem like you Or purpose, or you just don't curse. Do you curse a lot?
You don't seem like you do. I learned to curse. I didn't use to, but I can. And I do, I mean, maybe occasionally something slips out, but I really don't want them to curse in front of me, because I feel like you need to know that there are grown-ups you talk a certain way around, or that you behave a certain way around, and it might as well be me
So yeah, yeah, I really love that you're a good mom And you also have a busy day and we've taken a Time you have so many things to go do more important than talking to us But what an episode of our day with us. Um, but we're an after our day with a new. Yeah, my God. Big shot of sunshine. Yeah. Yeah. You know, thank you, Jen. So at least I didn't show you my bad hair. I can't let's say go back. Let's think about it. Any how can it be bad? It's long. Let's think about it. I don't know. We're gonna. Is that a strategy? Do you have a scrunchie on your wrist? Yeah, you got to be ready.
I like to do a scrunchy. I'm always doing scrunchy bits. Oh, yeah, look at it. Watch him do a scrunchy bit. And he just, yeah, I think my hair. And then he's ready to go. And then ready to go. Thank you for that.
And then stretch out the ponytail. Yes, stretch it out. No, I was thinking, yeah, you do this. I'm always doing this with it, you know, like you're doing. He does. Hey, guys, um, did anybody see where I parked? Where I left my hair is right. I love Sean.
I'll pick up somebody's purse at a party and just throw it over your shoulder. Guys, anybody anything from CVS? Yeah, I'm just running to CVS. And which way is out? Is that way? How do I get out of it? Also, anytime there's a candle anywhere on a table, whatever, Sean O'Lis grabs the candle, and then he, he'll shield the wind from the front of it.
She'll the wind. And I go guys this way, which way does that? The devil's been. The devil's been. Now, truly wasted your time. I learned so much. Thank you guys. Sorry, Jen.
No, thank you, Jennifer Garner. We love you. Thank you, Jennifer Garner. I love you, Jennifer. I love you. Thank you. I love you. Thank you. I love you. Thank you, Jennifer Garner. Love you, Jennifer. I love you. Thank you. I love you. Thank you. I love you. Last thing you told me on Apple Plus with Jennifer Garner, go and watch it immediately. Yeah. Do the right thing. Do the right thing. Bye. Bye, Jen. Guys, I feel like I got a, I got a, I got a personality shower. Yeah,
if I'm all clean, making to a flower who is just easy, easy, lovely, gorgeous, fun, funny talent. Right in the day. She made me feel better. Yeah. She made the day better. I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, remember 13 going on 30, which we do even ask her about. Yes, 13 going on 30. That was the movie I was thinking about.
She did it with Ruffalo, right? I think so, yeah. Is that right? Yeah, what about dresses? Wasn't there a bunch of dresses? Did she do that one? 19 dresses? 21 dresses?
I don't know. 17, 25 dresses. No, that was, remember she was in Dallas Buyers Club with, she's in Dallas Buyers Club. Oh my God, she won. 13 going on 30. I'm pretty sure it was.
Yes, a rough one. Listen, there doesn't want to hear us going down there. Her W I am W I just look it up. I was like, Oh my God. She's. No, she's done so much and she's always so. You're I always feel like she's one of those people. You're whatever she's in, whether it's in a movie or on TV or at some thing or even on a commercial,
you're all like, boy, I'm delighted to see Jen go. Yeah, absolutely. You know, I think one of America's sweethearts, absolutely. Even if she's asking me what's in my wallet, she's brightening up my commercial break. It's true. I know. Yeah, she does a bunch of those things. And it's so delightful.
And that's almost, I don't mean that thing. That thing that everybody talks about. We like you look at her like, I don't want to sit front. I'm kind of sending. No, no, no, no. Yeah, you want it like, I want to talk to Jennifer Garner. I feel like my day would feel better. I just did. Sure. But you know, but but conversely, you know, it would be awesome is to see her in some gnarly dramatic part where she's just fucking rip in some part. You son of a bet. You just unleashing. What if she's got that?
She's not that bad. Oh, man. Why? Well, I just to see you like to see an actor go from, you know, zero to a hundred, right? I don't know. Absolutely. I don't know if everybody needs to do everything to do the thing, be good at the thing you're good at.
Well, put it this way, can you imagine her in a bad mood? No. Right? So wouldn't it be fun in a character, in a part, to see her just like, it'd be like so like shocking. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. Like, if you were to see me in a part,
just being super nice and genuine to somebody. I wouldn't believe it. I wouldn't believe it for a second. But if I was doing a good job, it would be nice. I mean, they'd give you an Oscar. If you did that, you'd get a lifetime achievement award for that. Yeah, that's her test.
Sure, believe it. Yeah, I believe. I was there. I obviously like, when she, when I see her have asked her to believe it. I was there. I was there, like, when she, when I see her. Here he comes. Oh boy. Here he comes.
Sean, can I tell you something? I can tell you something. I can tell you something from a mile away. Because you know why I'm doing the roller-stores? It's a sensible player. Here comes the buy. Because the buy, if I buy a pull-up, can I buy a pull-up? Well, I never would.
Whenever I say something. I never, Scotty and I'd say, Fuffa. Oh. Oh. I know. Oh, wait a minute. Why don't we just, why don't we just go back start again? Why don't we just go back to saying goodbye?
Why don't we just say, hey, what a great show. I'll see you guys later. Never happens. Bye. Why don't we do that? So, what a great show. I'll see you guys later. Never happens. Bye. Why don't we do that? So, so far, far, far, far. So when I see Jennifer coming towards me, I always want to say, hi, I never want to say, oh, bye.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye! Ah! Smart! Smart! Smart!
Smart! Smart! SmartLess is 100% organic and artisnally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Granteri. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Smart, less. on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondri app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.